i have clients in fields that probably
are not going to change humanity or the
world uh for the better um
and i enjoy working with them they're
nice people but when you bring in
certainly in a sector like futek uh
where the potential is there it comes a
passion
and the passion really drives you to
help them out and make connections i try
to connect my clients to
others who might be helpful to them
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
on the legal side of tech with steven
resent partner at the law firm amit
pollak matalon and co and he's also
senior reserves officer at the rank of
lieutenant colonel in the idf
meet amit
i'm really excited to talk to you in the
least 20 minutes about you know your
yourself your journey your career today
you're from the firm that you're with
that you've been leading and and
particularly you know your role within
international relations and partnerships
between firm the legal side of the tech
world that we're all in in this amazing
ecosystem so we're gonna have a great
time and and stephen tell me a little
bit about you know your own personal you
know journey leading up to this firm
well i was uh born in upstate new york i
grew up in los angeles
uh
you know fairly uh regular from that
perspective i spent a lot of my
childhood in israel mainly summer
vacations along those lines
and i came to israel for my gap year
after high school and i was signed up
for university in america and i just
decided to stay
and i went to law school uh
straight out of high school in israel
went to the army after that and did six
years in the army as a lawyer as a jag
officer and finished the army and
decided to go into private practice
so so that year you came to israel for a
gap year this is a story that we hear
about sometimes not too not often enough
but what it is happening tell me a
little bit about you know your
perspective coming in straight out of
high school upstate new york and you're
and and all of a sudden you're finding
yourself in israel what was it about
this place that made you you know choose
to do something as i wouldn't say
extreme but as as meaningful as staying
here and at the end of listing
for a six year service that that doesn't
go away you know just easily
right so uh yeah i grew up in l.a it was
pretty common for a lot of the uh my
peers and my friends to come to israel
for a gap year after high school but we
were all signed up for universities in
america after that but i was here and in
the middle of the year i called up mom
and dad listen i don't see myself
leaving ever this is i see my future
being here
uh
you know i just i just loved it here
and uh you know thankfully it's worked
out really well israel uh certainly
nowadays is a very modern country you
can get everything
uh it's a great place to be it's uh
we're very fortunate uh for many aspects
uh to be in israel um 100 and you know
it's not israel of the 60s or the 70s of
the last uh century but
amazing
uh 100 yeah we're still working on our
amazon prime but we'll get to that one
day right
you're absolutely right and it's perfect
did you know that that law was was in
your trajectory you know coming into
israel after high school was it was it
obviously you're gonna go into law
um
it wasn't obvious uh from the outset
actually a lot of people who knew me
growing up uh were a little surprised
that i went to the law because they
thought i was going to go into something
you know computer science uh technology
that's what i was very involved with uh
since a young age
so i found a different way of doing that
i i decided to go into law uh something
that that did interest me for many years
before law school
and
i deal in tech law
so i deal in innovation i deal with a
lot of startups i deal with
multinational companies that are coming
to israel to invest in israeli
technology
um so i've kind of found the way to mesh
the passion for
technology for computers together with
the law
right and being you know illegal within
a military setting what was that like
for you
oh that that was very interesting it's
uh
i dealt with a lot of policy so you come
into the army you're fresh out of law
school
uh you have zero legal experience and
all of a sudden you find yourself i
personally found myself i was in the
general staff which is military
headquarters
uh
based in tel aviv and you find yourself
dealing with very senior military
officers who have been in combat
situations uh have led many troops into
battle and now you're setting policy for
the military at large so i remember my
first day uh of military service and my
commander
uh said
it's like a pendulum and
you're making a decision and it says one
small little change up here where you
are
swings the ball very widely at the at
the bottom for the rest of the military
and we have to be aware of that very
interesting it works with people that
um i don't think i'll ever get the
chance to work with again i i do in my
reserve duty but uh the ability to have
that great in effect on the army is
unbelievable
right and and you know your relationship
also with
with israel with judaism as well you
know it resonates i think throughout
your career as well whether it be
through your long-term work with uh
project genesis tura.org uh so that
dating back all the way to the inception
of the internet really right so you're
talking about your you know in computer
science you were there when computer
science was just taking off as the demo
is a democratized field that allows many
others to to enter it but now also in
your reserves you've been advising to
the chief military rabbi right which is
also very very i'm sure a very
interesting experience
talking about swinging the ball the
military setting being both very
innovative very combatant but at the
same time respecting
the respecting the country that we're in
and in the jewish part of the military
definitely it's a very interesting
position i've been working with the
current uh chief military abbey for 16
years now
uh and i work anything that uh if you're
in israel certainly that you see in the
news that has to deal with religion and
the military
uh i've dealt with and i'm dealing with
on a regular basis on active basis uh i
represented i was i was the
representative the minister of defense
in the constant recently with respect to
a law that was being uh deliberated on
um in my milo aim uh
so which is reserves duty in israel uh
and so it's very interesting i'm dealing
with a high high policy uh high-level
policy decisions that are being made and
the flip side also i receive uh
delegations from foreign militaries that
are coming to visit the idf rabinet so
i've received many delegations from the
us military on and we collaborate on
operative matters so
for me the ability to it's kind of like
my hobby uh this reserve duty to mesh uh
my day-to-day
working on technology and law and then
being able to go there and bring all of
my knowledge and figure out a way to
mesh it into dealing with uh military
policy is just unbelievable
fantastic so so transitioning more to
the private sector
over the last
almost 16 years today a partner and head
of international relationships with amid
pollock matalon and koch
tell me you know and
if you were talking about the firm for a
second so just to have the context of of
of where you've been
these last 15 and a half years well what
is this firm that you're a part of
and and and why specifically this firm
there's a lot of different firms again
you're right there's actually very many
good uh
there's very many very good law firms in
tel aviv that deal in the tech sector um
apm has been around for many many years
it's been around since 1956
uh and it deals with all areas of
commercial law uh very nice people very
personable uh we try to be very hands-on
with our clients um you know obviously
we're all good lawyers here and there's
a lot of very good lawyers in tel aviv
uh but it's a very personal firm very
nice people uh that's kind of what drew
me to the firm and what's kept me here
over the years uh and the firm has grown
together with all of the other firms in
tel aviv
each at their own pace but uh we've kept
up with the pace and
uh being a partner here has just been an
amazing experience
the work that we do here is unbelievable
being able to work
with multinational clients
who are thinking about israel
uh or some of them actually weren't even
thinking about israel and i managed to
interest them in israel
which to me to be able to mesh the
zionism
and the technology and doing better for
humanity and having it come outside of
israel
has been a very fulfilling experience
uh you know there's the saying that
we like israel to be a light unto the
nations and to be able to do that from a
tech perspective
to bring good israeli technology to the
world
develop it
have it a
better humanity
is been amazing and i've i've been able
to uh mix all of that together with
my own profession
so
it's it's a it's a triple win basically
it's it's for the country for humanity
and for me personally also
and we see it in many people also you
know and
you're holding a variety of very
interesting positions that are also you
know quite quite modern in their in
their importance you know one hand you
have still the connection to israel the
you know your role within you know
working with the israel innovation
authority really understanding its
tragedy's benefits this is something
that's ongoing and it's i believe pretty
recent in the ecosystem this ability for
a government to come in and and by
policy you know increasing the
innovation and and augmenting it
incentivizing it at the same time you're
also sharing the food tech in ag tech
sectors and companies that work with
apms also two fields that that are
relatively newer in their spotlight and
and how they're you know israel has
always been a you know a magic place for
agriculture and food but but now we're
seeing software also entered pretty
dramatically so the choice of working in
these fields how how did that come about
for you
probably like a lot of good things that
happened in life by chance
uh i didn't direct myself to the
innovation authority uh that happened
very much by chance the same thing with
futek individ israel just a little
background of this early invention
authority they are a long arm of the
israeli government they pump significant
money into the israeli tech sector every
year in order to encourage innovation
and to get the
private entrepreneurs
uh
running to help their companies get off
the ground but they also help them in
advanced stages an amazing amazing unit
of the government
they have set off a lot of the israeli
innovation and when i speak to foreign
delegations who come here foreign
lawmakers from the u.s from europe who
come here and try to figure out how
we're doing it in israel that's one of
the things that i talk to them about
obviously there's there's a lot of
different uh ingredients in making it
happen in israel and they say so what we
have to provide tax incentives they say
now tax incentives aren't going to do it
because tax incentives mean you're
making money and now you're going to pay
less taxes than you would otherwise here
it's before these companies are have
even made one dollar of revenue way
before that years before that the
israeli government is pumping money
giving literally giving them money in
order to operate and they hope something
will good will come out of it
uh and if something does come out of it
then the israeli government will start
to get their money back but
the
economic effect the layers upon layers
of what's happening are unbelievable
and that's why they've increased the
budget of the innovation authority year
after year after year over the past few
years and it's really had a big effect a
positive effect on the israeli tech
sector
futek it just started by chance we
started with one client in that sector
uh and you saw it it worked out well and
then we said okay why don't we uh and
then you get another client in that
sector and then
you know what you're on a roll and you
see you get more clients in that sector
and you become a real believer uh you
become really passionate for the field
the ability for foodtech to change
humanity
for the uh and the environment and the
planet you don't think of foodtech as
being something necessarily good for the
environment
uh when you start off you say okay we
all eat three times a day but what are
we putting into our bodies how are we
growing it and that's where food tech
has the real
ability or potential to be a game
changer it's we've seen companies that
are going to grow steaks in a lab as
opposed to growing cows and then taking
them to the slaughterhouse to eat them
so they're not trying to convince people
not to kill animals for the sake of the
animals they're saying here we're going
to create an alternative so if you're
a meat eater
you might be able to reduce your
consumption of
an animal that was grown and get
something that tastes basically the same
has the same nutritional value if not
better but it's going to be better for
the planet
so it's very interesting and then
there's
all these other companies you know maybe
they'll replace sugar
in your food with a protein that gives
off a sweet tasting uh flavor and the
list just goes on and on and it's all
coming out of israel so it's amazing
so you know in your position from the
firm's perspective and from the
company's perspective so obviously
there's a part of you know believing in
this vision believing in the mission you
know understanding the product better
what what is what are the benefits for
the companies having a lawyer like
yourself that that really understands
this field that has experience
specifically in where if we're talking
about food tech ag tech you know what is
the benefit of having an
a lawyer that really understands this
field and has experience in it rather
than just a you know a lawyer that is
great and has great understanding of
tech and m a's and and and financial
rounds what what where is the
differentiation here where is the added
well we're we're in a service sector so
you're not walking into a supermarket
taking something off the shelf and
putting in your cart uh you're working
with people
so it all comes down to
the person you're working with whether
you get along with them are they going
to make your life easier are they going
to
take problems off of your desk how
they're going to deal with it and what
value are they going to breed do you
like working with the person
so obviously the the starting assumption
is that they're good at what they do
that they know what they're doing
uh but but beyond that it's the question
is whether they care about what uh
you're doing as a client
um are they passionate about what
they're doing
so
yes i have clients in fields that
probably are not gonna change humanity
or the world uh for the better um
and i enjoy working with them they're
nice people but when you bring in
certainly in a sector like futek uh
where the potential is there it comes a
passion
and the passion really drives you to
help them out and make connections i try
to connect my clients
to uh others who might be helpful to
them in a non-legal uh
[Music]
method or not legal way to try to try to
help their business along to make
introductions to see what we can do for
them in a non-legal setting and my
clients feel it they feel that i'm
passionate about what i'm doing and
that's what really makes it uh
different coming to work every day and
to know you're not just a pencil
pusher uh you're not just filing the
papers or creating the documents you're
doing something that you feel might have
a real benefit
to the world at large
for children for our grandchildren and
you're enjoying it and that makes all
the difference
so the what are the modes of interaction
really between yourself and a client
perhaps in in in the line of business
that you're in what where do these
points of interaction come across is it
mainly you know you know every few years
once there's an an interesting legal
activity that is happening like a
financing round or liquidation event or
is it more ongoing and so in other words
also how do you keep up with what's
happening with a company between these
you know legal worthiness so i've been
very blessed that uh i like working with
my clients i don't uh have any clients
that i don't enjoy working with uh i i
appreciate that that might not be the
situation for most lawyers certainly not
if you're just getting started but
over the years i've been able to refine
it in that perspective and
i speak with my clients on a regular
basis i enjoy keeping up with what
they're doing understanding where they
are they will call me up and ask me for
advice for business advice
uh how do we deal with a certain
situation not just from a legal
perspective but how do we deal with it
uh from a business uh from a strategic
perspective
uh how do we deal with a certain
situation that is arisen what do we
propose and that's where we bring a lot
of value into the equation uh just the
law while it's interesting uh it's not
interesting enough
uh it's the ability to be able to get
involved in the business side of things
that's what we get involved with that's
what they consult us with so we become
really involved on a day-to-day basis
and that's why clients might call me up
on a friday morning and i'll take their
call
because i i believe in what they're
trying to achieve
and they want to speak to me because the
situation has arisen where they need my
advice
incredible if you're looking now in your
you know your journey you're just
what what really gets you going you know
and what you do i'm hearing the passion
for the domains and hearing the passion
for working with the clients and hearing
the passion for israel
where i'm also hearing the passion for
being able to to work with a variety of
different problems in a variety of
different projects
where where what are these really
magical moments
that you're sitting back and saying wow
i'm so lucky to be doing this well it's
not uh uh
thursday night at three in the morning
that's for sure
at that point you'd rather be uh
uh sleeping in bed at home as opposed to
an office and those moments do arise um
it goes together with uh
with this field of law
but the moments arise when you see
clients succeeding and you know that you
were very involved in what happened when
the client turns around and says thank
you stephen for helping me make this
happen
and uh that's that's an amazing moment
that you say listen i had a real
difference here i just for example uh
there was a tender uh to operate uh
technological incubators that was
published by the israeli innovation
authority and one of the groups that one
was my clients and we helped them put
the consortium together in a field
called space tech
the new field uh that is is uh
you know coming out in israel uh over
the world you see elon musk
and others where you can go in basically
if you have enough fun you can buy a
ticket
to fly into space so
and people are talking about going back
to the moon but the moon is not the new
challenge it's going to mars has become
the challenge so you see these people in
space tech
and we're going to develop here in
israel technologies that will deal with
it so this consortium of companies
was a consortium that
me and my partners put together we
literally connected investors
multinationals to entrepreneurs in order
to go in and vie for this tender and
they turned around and said guys thank
you so much steven and your partners
you were the ones who made this happen
and
i very much believe in the butterfly
effect so if we look five years from now
ten years from now the companies that
will come out of this incubator
uh that will be developed from here that
would see their first investment from
here i have a hand in that in my own
little fashion
and it's just amazing to look at that
and the potential when you go down the
line as to what might come out of this
for humanity well i really had the
ability to make this happen
so that to me is bringing a lot of value
to the client and i enjoy it it's so not
just business
it's being there being actively involved
i like it
i love it and i think that that sentence
it's so not just business
uh
i think that really summarizes and
captures the theme of this conversation
and stephen i really want to thank you
for for your time here and for for the
energy and for the great work that
you're doing not just for your clients
but also for the state of israel
and i really enjoyed this conversation
thank you very very much thank you
michael thank you for having me i
appreciate it i enjoyed it as well
[Music]